we've been extensively covering the
growing civil war within the republican
party the battle lines are not super
clear but to some degree at least at the
very top level the battle lines are
pro-trump and anti-trump republicans and
one really interesting figure
in that
is florida governor ron desantis and
he's interesting because it's not
exactly clear which side he's on and
what i mean by that is early in the
pandemic when the failed former
president donald trump was still the
actively failing president donald trump
ron desantis and trump were very
buddy-buddy early in the pandemic
desantis refused to close
and or very quickly opened major events
sporting events all sorts of different
things trump pointed to desantis as a
guy doing the right thing and they were
very buddy buddy
over time it started to become clear
that there was at least some appetite
from within the republican party for an
alternative to trump and while the
alternative that they seem to be seeking
is not
you know mitt romney
uh it's it's ron desantis to some degree
ron desantis has increasingly been
thought of as an alternative to trump
now it's weird because desantis is
almost like trump to the nth degree
desantis has a lot of the same terrible
ideas of trump the same political
instinct of trump but he's more
competent and he's less cartoonish and
he's probably more dangerous if he gets
the opportunity to be president of the
united states but so kind of by default
there started to be this well will it be
trump 2024 or will it be desantis 2024
and this has really triggered donald
trump to the point where we now have
multiple reports we've told you about
where trump is reportedly furious that
for example when desantis has asked hey
will you run in 2024 desantis doesn't go
oh absolutely not it's trump's for the
taking desantis hasn't said that and
there are numerous reports that trump
and people around him are upset about
that this brings us to this past weekend
uh at mar-a-lago and at mar-a-lago uh
roger stone who was a guest on this
program and was uh was ultimately
convicted and then pardoned and he's a
friend of trump okay whatever roger
stone was filmed at mar-a-lago and he
goes up to trump and he says ron
desantis is a piece of s
and
that video was initially kind of cut so
you don't really see what trump's
reaction is
now the fuller video has been released
i'm going to play it for you now of
course if you're listening you're not
going to know what trump does but the
big deal that's being made is trump nods
when roger stone tells them ron desantis
is a piece of s let's take a look at the
video let's take a listen to the video
have a good time
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
okay
so listen this is not like the big
smoking gun that trump has declared
declared you know open season on ron
desantis or anything like it there's
also we we can't ignore that there's
really strange kind of like godfather
vibes uh at the start of the first
godfather movie incredible movie uh by
the way uh when i sometimes when i
mention the godfather people email
saying i'm glorifying violence because
it's a violent film no it's just a great
film uh the scene at the wedding where
everybody is kind of making their
pilgrimages and saying hello thank you
godfather i have a favor i need this i
need that oh you're so great there's a
similar vibe to it that's developed at
mar-a-lago with people coming and making
their pilgrimages to trump but putting
that aside um there is no question that
donald trump is now hostile to ron
desantis and it's increasingly clear
that voters are aware that there is an
alternative to donald donald trump so
we've looked at these numbers before and
they continue to improve slightly and
ron desantis favor if you go to
predicted.org where you can bet on who
will be you can bet on almost anything
they'll take your action but one of the
things is you can bet on who will be the
2024 republican nominee
last time we looked at this it was 39.29
39
believed it would be trump and 29
believed it would be desantis that was
the closest it had been since the start
of uh you know of the discussion of
2024. it is now tightened up a little
bit more where now it is 38.30 this is
based on money betting these aren't
polls but if you look at how people are
betting
38 now believe trump will be the nominee
and 30 believe it will be ron desantis
there is no way trump's not aware of
these numbers
and desantis is quickly gaining ground
on donald trump this is the tightest
that it's been now if you look at actual
polling the most recent polling i found
is from a couple months ago actually
almost three months ago
and there
you had trump at 57 percent
this was a harvard caps harris poll it
had three months ago trump was at 57
among republicans
and desantis and pence each had 12. now
that's three months ago the numbers may
well have tightened since then but there
is
let me put it a different way
it is not a foregone conclusion that if
there is a contested 24 primary and
trump runs and desantis runs that trump
runs away with it there
desantis has growing support
and increasingly people believe
he has a real shot and that's the first
step in having a shot people believing
you have a shot it becomes a sort of
self-fulfilling prophecy so expect that
it will get delightfully ugly if both
trump and desantis keep pointing towards
i may indeed run let me know your
thoughts we'll have the clip of roger
stone and trump at mar-a-lago
on our instagram which you can find at
david pakman show
i'm really excited that uh one of our
sponsors today is helix sleep i sleep on
a helix mattress at home i absolutely
love it and that's why i reached out to
them about sponsoring the david pakman
show
buying a mattress in the past
was always a huge guessing game for me i
didn't know what i actually needed i
didn't know what i would like but helix
has a sleep quiz on their website you
tell them your body type your sleeping
position your back pain issues you might
have and their tool matched me with a
mattress that is perfect for me it's
cool enough at night it's the right
firmness i generally just do way better
sleeping these days because of the
mattress helix was awarded number one
best overall mattress for the last two
years by both gq and wired magazine it
is well deserved i can tell you
firsthand every helix mattress comes
with a 10-year warranty you can try the
mattress risk free for 100 nights and
they will even come pick it up at your
house if you don't love it but i know
you will all of my viewers will get up
to 200 off your order and you'll get two
super premium pillows for free
when you go to the link right underneath
this video